[Musique]
sciences po grenoble n'est plus un
institut d'études politiques mais
d'éducation voire de rééducation dans un
certain nombre de quartiers en gros
ghettoïser où les jeunes vivent en
autarcie culturelle religieuse
voilà les les prédicateurs islamistes
sont comme un poisson dans l'eau il ya
la transformation de ce
monde aurélia avec une police de la
pensée ou une minorité exerce son
pouvoir quand la marge majorité qui est
intimidé qui se couchent
2426 malades en soins critiques ce matin
ils étaient 1000 il y a deux points
désormais plus que lors de la quatrième
vague dont le pic avait été atteint en
mois de septembre il ya désormais un
malade qui rentrent en réanimation
toutes les six minutes dans notre pays
si vous vous souvenez jeudi dernier j'ai
parlé d'une admission en réanimation
toutes les dix minutes ce qui veut dire
que ça s'accélère en terme de pression
sanitaire dans notre pays qui par
ailleurs je me fais le porte voix de
plusieurs de mes confrères serez vous
candidat à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
merci selon la presse britannique
plusieurs fêtes ont été organisées par
les équipes de boris johnson alors que
les rassemblements étaient interdits
pour l'ensemble du pays des clowns
s'indigne le quotidien métro une
mauvaise blague pour le daily mail je ne
répondrai évidemment pas aux dernières
questions ce jour mais je veux
simplement vous dire mais c'est normal
que vous la pose y est je respecte tout
à fait je peux comprendre à quel point
il doit être exaspérant de se dire que
les personnes qui ont fixé les règles
n'ont pas suivi les règles je prends
très bien
d'abord je le prends comme un signe
d'affection
un désir caché
presque un appel vous participez à la
primaire de la gauche proposée par un
hidalgo non pourquoi coup de théâtre à
gauche naudy le télégramme qui nous
rappelle qu'anne hidalgo étaient opposés
à cette idée de primaire il ya encore
quelques semaines maux de tête à gauche
s'affrontent tous étaient surpris de
découvrir sa déclaration comme celle
d'arnaud montebourg d'ailleurs comme si
d'ailleurs les deux c'était un peu
coordonnés mais je suis prêt à offrir ma
candidature un projet commun et un
candidat communs et j'invite mes
concurrents et mes camarades à faire de
même s'il doute de leur candidature mais
travaillons ensemble et effectivement
travail ont un programme enfin pied un
programme commun nous les communistes on
sait ce que c'est aujourd'hui nous
sommes éliminés faut dépasser dépasser
nos clivages ensemble nous pouvons
challenge et monsieur macron challenge
aime madame pécresse challenge l extrême
dans ce pays des positions très
différentes à gauche on va pas comme ça
les résoudre avec quelque chose qui
signifierait qu'en fait on peut mettre
l'un à la place de l'autre évidemment ça
n'a aucune importance ce n'est pas le
cas je pense que ce n'est pas au service
ni à la gauche ni au peuple français que
de ce que ceux de faire ce genre de
manoeuvre nous nous sommes prêts à
gagner nous sommes prêts à gouverner et
c'est ça dont nous voulons convaincre
les français les français en tout cas
c'est pas le choix des écologistes choix
qu'il a mais vous ne serez pas je ne
participerai pas à une primaire de la
gauche parce que l'élection c'est dans
quatre mois et demi c'est du bricolage
c'est de l'improvisation je crois
qu'elle a prévenu personne même au sein
des socialistes donc pour moi ça masque
le fait que finalement la candidate
socialiste constate l'impasse de la
social-démocratie en les vents mauvais
revienne
et se lève
il est légitime qu'il y ait des choix
démocratiques et que toutes les voix
s'expriment mais le rôle de nos
institutions
et de tenir le pays là où il doit être
qu'une quotidien d'union date sens que
si un programme commun ne rien concéder
ni au racisme ni à l'antisémitisme ni à
la remise en cause de nos valeurs ni à
la manipulation de notre histoire oui
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu dire des gens
que c'était une manière d'habiller son
retrait pour vous celle là c'est
peut-être ça